(typing)
(loud groaning)
- Either we throw an
intervention or call the cops.
I'm sick of the break room
smelling like Arby's and tears.
- Let's heal him through
the power of song, guys.
For example.
(off key singing)
♪ Live together in
a pond of dreams
♪ With clouds for feet
♪ And dogs for friends
- I'm a star.
I'm a big bright shining star.
- Are those my ear muffs?
- You're just jealous I
got bigger tits than you.
Burn!
- You just insulted you.
- I'm so excited.
I'm so excited.
I'm so...
(thud)
Scared.
(plopping)
(coughing)
Oh my butt hole's filled
with nickels and secrets.
♪ Oh we got it made
♪ Yeah, nothing's
gonna get us down
♪ Everything's perfect
♪ 'Cause baby we got it made
- I don't think
I have a problem.
- You're drinking right now.
- You're drinking a diet coke!
- Diet coke doesn't get me
kicked out of Planet Hollywood
for rubbing my face in the
Jack and Jill memorabilia.
- It was a good movie!
- You gotta start going to AA.
- Last time I went,
they made me play cards
and wear a cape, so.
- Motherfucker, that wasn't AA,
that was Dungeons and Dragons!
You blacked out,
barged into a Comic-Con
and spent 20 minutes trying
to finger a Somali girl
dressed as a wizard.
- I'm not a perfect man,
but neither are you guys.
Elmer's into erotic
space literature,
Lyle's really unlikable,
and Anita, you...
Uh, fat?
Ah!
- You fat as fuck.
- I'm classically handsome
like Jarrod Deprado
or the Quaker Oats guy.
- I wrote something
for the occasion.
- Here we go.
- Dear Richie,
I wake up in the
morning disappointed
in you, in my leader.
Queen Babala approaches,
engaging me with her three
magnificent breasts, her
steaming vulva bubbles
like a bowl of beefaroni.
- Elmer, no erotic space lit.
- I guess I could stop.
Okay.
Okay, I quit.
(clapping)
Always wanted to open up that
wild west themed
bed and breakfast.
Maybe I can get it
off the ground now.
Yeah!
Slow clap to real
clap, fuck you stepdad.
- Now that you don't drink
you'll have time for other stuff
like that--
- So much time!
We can hang out more as a gang.
Take one of those bear
building classes together.
Wouldn't that be
a fun, wacky time?
All of us building bears?
How does Tuesday at 10 AM sound?
Wednesday at 10 AM?
Thursday, really any
time now that I'm sober.
'Cause I'm not just
building bears,
I'm building friendships.
You guys are dicks.
- I liked your story, Elmer.
- Thanks.
I wrote another
one where Chewbacca
asked Buffy to marry him.
Don't worry, Richie,
she says yes.
♪ We got it made
♪ Yeah nothing's
going to get us down
♪ Everything's perfect